it's been nearly a decade since the
release of zack snyder's sucker punch
to sort through our many conflicting
feelings about this mind-bending action
thriller
we're giving the film another look and
examining all the things we still don't
understand about it
but first a word of warning major
spoilers are ahead
after accidentally killing her sister
while trying to protect her from their
abusive stepfather
a young woman only known as baby doll
ends up in a mental asylum
from the moment she arrives she's at the
mercy of a corrupt and vicious orderly
named blue
with just five days remaining until baby
doll is scheduled to be lobotomized
she teams up with four other inmates to
plot a daring breakout
now this is where things start to get a
little tricky
as baby doll works towards escaping
physically she appears to be escaping
her bonds mentally as well
she starts imagining fantastical worlds
in which she
and her crew are powerful heroes going
on a series of grand adventures
it's all a bit complicated so let's
break it down step by step
sucker punch operates on three levels of
reality the first
is the real world which is the corrupt
mental asylum where it seems that baby
doll
and the other patients are victimized by
the staff
the second level is a nightclub that
also functions as a brothel for its
wealthy clients
babydoll imagines that the asylum is in
fact this dangerous nightclub
run by a violent and possessive mobster
the third level of reality is babydoll's
totally fantastical and heroic world of
adventures which is always said to
modern rock and pop music
we completely understand the asylum
that's the real world
we also basically understand the fantasy
sequences
babydoll imagines a place in which she's
powerful because in the actual world
she's not but it's that second layer of
reality
the nightclub and the brothel that has
us confused
it certainly isn't functioning as
escapism for any of the female
characters
the imaginary brothel is no less hostile
than the asylum just slightly different
we can't really think of a deeper
thematic or artistic motivation behind
its inclusion
apart from being an excuse to dress up
all the female characters in mini skirts
and lingerie
this is a joke right unless we're
missing something
we can't figure out what the film would
lose if you cut out the brothel
and only had two levels of reality
instead of three
the tone would be the same the trauma
would be the same
all that would change are the costumes
and color palette oh
and the fact that the characters
wouldn't be in a brothel
each time babydoll dances in the
nightclub reality she's temporarily
transported to a different fantastical
world full of enemies and monsters that
she must slay
she's faced with everything from giant
samurai to zombie steampunk soldiers to
killer robots
the implication is that these are
babydolls dreams but
why would a young person from the
mid-1900s be dreaming in the tropes of
modern geek culture
that would be crazy however there's a
version of this that could have worked
in movies a character's dreams are a
general reflection
in some way of who that person is
director zack snyder has stated in
interviews that the comics magazine
heavy metal was a major inspiration for
sucker punch
so perhaps baby doll herself could have
also been established as a comic book
fan
or even better she could have been an
aspiring writer or artist who was just a
couple decades ahead of her time
dreaming of fictional worlds that didn't
exist yet
for much of the movie it seems as if the
filmmakers treat babydoll much the same
way as her captors do
simply as a means to an end an object
that only exists to fulfill their wishes
she isn't really a person and her inner
life doesn't matter
these sequences are rather transparently
just the writer's fantasies
and not hers baby doll and her friends
are fighting enemies in a fantasy
sequence they're also dealing with a
problem in the nightclub reality
however most of the time the actions
they're performing within a fantasy
seem to have little to do with the
corresponding goals they're trying to
achieve outside of it
do the specifics of these fantasies
actually matter to the real world
or are they just supposed to look really
cool for instance
in one sequence babydoll is distracting
a wealthy man by dancing while another
woman amber steals a lighter from his
jacket
in the fantasy however amber is
providing air cover from a plane so that
baby doll can sneak up on a baby dragon
and steal a pair of magic crystals the
action is a complete inversion
of what's actually happening in the
nightclub level of reality for
no apparent reason and it makes it
difficult to get emotionally invested in
the dragon slaying scene
one notable exception to this lack of
cohesion occurs when the women are
trying to steal a kitchen knife
when they fail and rocket gets stabbed
by the cook in the nightclub reality
we cut back to the fantasy world where
rocket heroically sacrifices herself to
save her friends
it's one of the stronger moments in the
film primarily because the specifics of
the fantasy sequences
actually mean something a popular fan
theory about sucker punch is that
babydoll
isn't actually the point of view
character in truth
the entire story is being told in past
tense by sweet pea
the only woman who actually escaped some
take this theory even further asserting
that baby doll herself
never existed and she's an alternate
persona that sweetpea invented for
herself
a flawless superhero that sweepy
pretended to be so she could gather the
strength to break free of the asylum
this was never my story
it's yours now don't screw it up okay
so possibly sweetpea invented the
character of babydoll because
even if she couldn't personally imagine
slaying the dragons in her own life she
could imagine another person
a hero who could lie to yourself if you
must
tell yourself that you have superpowers
and there's no obstacle you can't
overcome
or to put it another way you have all
the weapons you need
now fight after the crew's plan to
escape
fails things don't end well for most of
them
rocket is killed by the cook then
blondie and amber are executed by blue
in the dressing room of the nightclub
in the end only sweetpea is able to
survive and escape
but remember all of this is only
happening in the imaginary world of the
nightclub
and not the real world of the asylum we
do get a few brief scenes in the asylum
after those tragedies but rocket amber
and blondie are nowhere to be seen
were they actually killed if you die in
the nightclub do you die in real life
the only hints that we get are courtesy
of dr gorski when she offers a brief
account of babydoll's eventful five days
in the asylum she stabbed an orderly
started a fire and and helped another
patient to
escape however she doesn't say
anything about an orderly name blue
openly executing two other patients in
front of her
additionally given that blue is
eventually arrested for authorizing
medical procedures in gorski's name
without her permission you'd imagine
that openly murdering patients would be
much bigger news
it makes sense if blue is a powerful and
violent mobster and gorski's working for
him
but it doesn't make sense at all if he's
a mere orderly and she's a doctor
who presumably outranks him however
things went down in the real version of
baby doll's attempted escape
it was probably quite different and
whether or not rocket
blondie and amber died in real life
that's just one of the many things we'll
never know
there's little in sucker punch that's as
confusing as the mysterious wise man who
appears in baby dolls fantasy battle
sequences this enigmatic figure
typically offers baby doll and her team
advice in the form of trite bumper
sticker truisms
for those who fight for life has a
flavor
the shelter will never know
even more puzzling these words of wisdom
consistently have no discernible
relevance to the crew's current
situation
nor do they relate to the movie's deeper
themes so
why is this character in the film we get
an answer
sort of in the final scene as sweetpea
is boarding the bus that will take her
to freedom
some police officers start asking her
questions suspecting that she's an
escaped mental patient
fortunately the bus driver steps in and
convinces them to leave her alone
this character is played by scott glenn
who also portrayed the wise man
one potential interpretation makes sense
if as we mentioned earlier
sweet pea has been the protagonist all
along and she's telling her story in the
past tense
since all these fantasies are really
hers perhaps she chose to retroactively
cast this man who saved her on the bus
as a mentor figure throughout her entire
story if so
we can't help but wonder why she
wouldn't cast gorski in that role
instead
she was helping all the women stay alive
the entire time
and not just at the very last minute i
teach them
to survive you
sucker punch definitely has some
problematic moments and most have to do
with how the film treats its female
characters
the issue isn't that it's about abuse
plenty of films about exploitation
aren't themselves exploitative consider
mad max fury road
just like sucker punch the plot centers
on women who are attempting to free
themselves from a terrible situation
their roads to freedom are similarly
long and dangerous
and not all of them make it what fury
road understands however
is that even though characters within
the film may treat women as if they're
objects the film itself should always
treat them like people
the main female characters get clearly
defined personalities
wants and conflicting philosophies
though sucker punch's heart may be in a
similar place
it falls short of the mark in its
execution the film's female heroes are
more or less interchangeable barbie
dolls with minimal dialogue
and indistinct personalities they exist
only to be stared at
tortured and eventually killed for shock
value
contrast this with how the movie treats
the primary abuser
blue he's perhaps the most complex
three-dimensional character in the film
and his numerous lengthy monologues mean
that he has easily twice as much
dialogue as any woman
this sadly proves that sucker punch can
make a character interesting
when he cares about that he just didn't
care enough about its female heroes to
do this
sucker punch is often accused of being a
shallow and exploitative film that only
exists as an excuse to show women in
miniskirts fighting in slow motion
for all the harsh things we've said
about the film so far we don't think
that's entirely fair
the film is clearly trying to make some
sort of deeper point
so let's give it the benefit of the
doubt and try to figure out what the
filmmakers might be trying to say
within the context of the fantasy
sequences sucker punch mimics the tropes
of senseless and seductive action films
this practice of filming women in an
objectifying way to bring pleasure to
the viewer
is often referred to as the male gaze a
term coined by film theorist laura
mulvey
sucker punch however might be attempting
to challenge this paradigm
through additional layers of reality the
asylum and the nightclub
the film equates the objectification of
women in film with the dehumanization
they experience in real life
which could be interpreted as a
condemnation of both forms of
exploitation
all of this culminates in the scene of
baby doll's lobotomy
when she's stabbed in the eye so is the
viewer the male gaze is penetrated
our happy ending deny we think we're
getting a fun escapist fantasy
and instead the ending of the film hits
us like well
a sucker punch so what's the final
verdict
is sucker punch pure exploitation or a
statement about it
in truth it's sort of both but more than
anything it's just confused
the film takes a stab at a feminist
message but whatever it's trying to say
gets lost in a web of
shallow characters dead end plot threads
and inexplicable narrative choices
if you just haven't wanted to just take
something back
that being said for all the film's
faults a lack of ambition is not one of
them
there were plenty of bigger than life
action scenes stunning imagery and
genuinely outrageous concepts
we'd much rather that filmmakers take
big swings like this one
even if they miss and fall down in
spectacular fashion
wow
so much for that little experiment
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus
even more looper videos about
over-the-top action movies are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]